[Music]
how long can a virus keep attacking me
especially when i've been previously
infected
how long do my antibodies survive in my
blood
how long does a vaccine defend my immune
system
against an intruder
scientists are grappling with these
questions
and we have yet to find out for certain
how long
vaccine protection lasts
welcome to our covered 19 special i'm
monica jones thanks for joining now
since the pandemic started we're all
hoping to regain the freedoms we enjoyed
before the global crisis
in countries with low infection rates
people who are fully vaccinated or who
fully recovered from kobe 19
can travel go to restaurants museums
theaters or nightclubs
and that is because they're thought to
be immune to the virus and less likely
to pass it on to others
but can we trust our immune system and
our
immune response against zarzakov too and
if so
for how long how long do people who've
had a mild or moderate case of covid19
remain immune
lubeck university research has teamed up
with the local health authority to find
out
they examined the blood of more than 400
volunteers at varying intervals
we ham the fact we wanted to find out
what the immune response was
and how best to study it in the blood
you find the antibodies as well as the t
lymphocytes which are part of the immune
system
and are very important for the
development of antibodies
t lymphocytes or t cells are white blood
cells
essential in activating a variety of
immune responses
with enough antibodies and t cells in
your blood you're protected against
infections
most of the patients developed
antibodies after about four weeks of
infection
within the next two months the
antibodies increased and peaked
and then dropped off slowly again over
time
but after about 10 months around half
the antibodies were still there
so the sphere uh we can assume that for
at least the 10 months of our study
those patients were protected
the researchers expect immunity to last
for over a year
they say the same is true for those
who've been vaccinated against covid19
from all the data gathered in between
times we now know that the creation of
antibodies after the vaccination
is in principle comparable to having had
the infection
but without having to suffer the
consequences of the illness
so our results are in this respect
transferable to the results one would
have after a vaccination
that means those who are vaccinated are
immune for at least 10 months and with a
strong immune system
possibly much longer
this is of course a further incentive
for people to get vaccinated
and naturally that's something we from
the health department support and
promote
because it's one of the most effective
ways out of this pandemic
the study also shows that after some
time booster shots will be needed
as with the annual influenza vaccination
professor miles davenport is head of the
infection analytics program
at the university of new south wales and
he joins us now good to have you with us
uh so i guess the first question
would definitely have to be i mean when
it comes to the level of immunity
against cyrus kov2
does it actually matter whether you
recovered from covid19
or whether you got vaccinated
uh the level of antibodies that you see
varies quite a lot between different
vaccines so the stronger vaccines
give about four fold higher antibody
levels than
a natural infection and the weaker
vaccines give
around half the antibody levels that you
see in natural infection
so there's quite a variability right
but there's also a difference between
falling seriously ill with cobit 19
and just having mild symptoms does this
also reflect
in the level of antibodies
it does seem that people that have had
more severe infection
um develop larger immune responses
afterwards
but that's not quite as big a difference
as for example
the strong vaccines versus the weak
vaccines in terms of the the antibody
level
do we know already how long people who
either recovered
or get vaccinated actually remain immune
to cyrus kovi too
because this already talked about
booster shots uh given
maybe half a year after being fully uh
vaccinated does this mean that basically
we cease to be immune after six months
well there's a very recent study um from
the pfizer vaccine
uh which just came out looking at uh the
level of protection that vaccine gives
and they claimed 96 protection within
the first two months
ninety percent between two and four
months and dropping to eighty four
percent
beyond four months but one thing that i
would emphasize here
is that that's measuring susceptibility
to any symptomatic infection
so much of that infection might be very
mild
and we expect that protection from
severe infection
uh will be much longer lasting because
you require a lower immune response to
protect
from severe infection because you just
mentioned uh that study by biontech
fisa when we talk about the booster shot
uh does this only apply to mrna vaccines
or would this apply to all the other
ones as well
uh so there's been quite a lot of work
uh looking at boosting people who've
been previously infected
um and that shows that boosting can give
probably a four times higher
antibody level um in a previously
infected person compared to a naive
person
there's more limited studies in boosting
vaccine responses
but you can probably use any vaccine to
boost
and it will be it may have again that
difference in the
strength of the effect but there's no
reason why you couldn't use any vaccine
to boost
when we talk about those antibody levels
i mean how many antibodies
do we actually need to have how many
antibodies are healthy
can there be a level that is way too
high
uh i don't think there's a level that's
way too high the way that we
measure the antibodies
commonly is to look at their ability to
neutralize the virus
so that's by taking the virus itself and
cells
in culture and looking at how much of a
patient's serum for example you need to
add to block
infection and that's what we call the
neutralizing teter of antibodies the
concentration you need to add
as far as we know um there's probably no
such thing as
too uh too many antibodies to the virus
um so i don't think that's a risk
uh i mean we do hear about people uh
catching that virus sars kov2 a second
time after
even after they've been vaccinated or
even after they fully
uh recovered so what kind of responses
are necessary to provide
protective immunity against this virus
i think it's perhaps again important to
define what you mean by protective
immunity
so there's protection from becoming
infected and there's protection from
severe infection
and so far it seems that these
neutralizing antibodies and the level of
neutralizing antibodies is very
predictive of protection
from infection uh but even
if the strongest vaccines they have an
efficacy around 95
so still five percent of people will get
infected but most of those
will have a very mild illness um
and and we hope that that protection
from severe infection will be
long-lasting
it's perhaps worth drawing a parallel uh
with influenza virus
where the virus circulates in the
community every year and most people
get infected quite often every few years
because of exposure however severe
infection is
fairly rare in the community because we
all have
sufficient protection and it's quite
likely that with
sarskoff ii the same thing will happen
that we can expect that infection will
be ongoing
but hopefully most people will be
protected from the more severe effects
yeah we all hope that same professor
dave import there from the university of
new south wales thank you so much for
your time
thank you so vaccine tricks our body
into thinking it's under attack thus
producing antibodies but
what else are vaccines doing to us time
to ask derek
[Music]
what systems exist in the eu for the
ongoing monitoring
of vaccine side effects
the central authority responsible for
for recommending
and monitoring vaccines in the european
union
is the european medicines agency or or
ema
which was set up to harmonize
these kinds of activities in the block
the vaccines green lighted so far
in a conditional market approval in the
eu
are now in what's often called a phase
four
when a vaccine is rolled out to the
public
on a wide scale but even after that
happens
clinical trials continue and and the
vaccines
are monitored closely for years
the monitoring tracks long-term
effectiveness of course but it's also
set up
to identify any adverse reactions or
other potential dangers
that were missed in earlier large scale
trials
so so what's called a pharmacovigilance
system is in place
it's it's pretty complex but also pretty
tightly networked and and the agency
says
it helps any reports from patients and
from healthcare professionals
to be analyzed extensively a lot of
people
distrust information issued directly by
pharmaceutical companies when it comes
to
how safe and effective they say their
products are
to assuage that distrust and help
promote transparency
the ema set up its own network and
management system
for for tracking suspected side effects
of
of not just vaccines but of any
medication approved in the eu
the european database is called yudra
vigilance
in it you can read any reports of
suspected
adverse vaccine effects on on a country
by country basis
and it's updated every week so if you're
interested
and want to see what's being reported
firsthand i urge you to take a look
it's really informative and and it's
easy to use
and that's all for today thanks for
watching
[Music]